cuáles son las soluciones del sistema de
ecuaciones de igual a x1 y x cuadrada
massieu cuadrada igual a 25
tratemos primero de visualizar el
problema para empezar vamos a esbozar la
gráfica de estas ecuaciones
aquí tenemos nuestro eje y y este de
aquí es nuestro eje x la gráfica de esta
ecuación de x cuadrada massieu cuadrada
igual a 25 corresponde a un círculo con
centro en el origen y radio 5
no hay que saber eso para resolver el
problema pero ayuda a visualizar aquí
tenemos 5 para la y 5 para la x menos 5
para la x y menos 5 para la ye entonces
voy a dibujar lo mejor posible la
circunferencia la ecuación va a estar
representada por este conjunto de puntos
o también podríamos decir que este es el
conjunto de puntos que cumple con esa
ecuación ahora de igual a x + 1 y igual
a x 1 es una recta con pendiente uno y
con ordenada al origen de uno esto
uno dos tres cuatro aquí tenemos la
ordenada al origen y con pendiente 1 así
es que la recta se va a ver más o menos
así cuando buscamos las soluciones
estamos buscando los puntos que
satisfacen ambas ecuaciones que son los
puntos que se encuentran en ambas
gráficas lo voy a hacer en verde aquí
tenemos uno y aquí tenemos el otro punto
ahora como los calculamos la manera más
fácil
bueno en ocasiones la manera más fácil
es sustituir una de las restricciones en
la otra restricción como aquí ya está
despejada la aie podemos sustituir este
valor de y en la ecuación azul vamos a
incluir en la ecuación la restricción ya
igual a x + 1 entonces esta ecuación
queda como x cuadrada más en vez de y
vamos a poner la restricción igual a x +
esto nos queda entonces como
x 1 x 1 elevado al cuadrado y esto tiene
que ser igual a 25 hagamos el álgebra
ahora para resolver la ecuación para x
esto es x cuadrada más ahora
desarrollamos este binomio al cuadrado
para obtener x cuadrada más 2 x + 1 y
esto tiene que ser igual a 25 la
ecuación nos queda ahora 2x cuadrada eso
es esta suma más 2 x más 1 igual a 25
ahora podemos usar la fórmula cuadrática
para encontrar las soluciones de esta
ecuación aunque espera hay que tener
cuidado primero hay que igualar la
ecuación a cero para aplicar la fórmula
cuadrática estamos 25 ambos lados nos
queda 2x cuadrada más 2 x menos 24 eso
es igual a 0 para simplificar esto
podemos dividir a ambos lados entre 2
nos queda el lado izquierdo x cuadrada
más x menos 12 y esto es igual a 0 y
vemos que no necesitamos usar la fórmula
cuadrática podemos factorizar este
expresa
necesitamos encontrar los números que al
multiplicarlos da menos 12 y al sumarlos
da 1 bien 4 y 3 son nuestros números
mágicos así es que esto lo podemos
factorizar como x + 4 por x 3 y esto es
igual a cero ahora las soluciones son x
es igual a bueno si x + 4 es igual a 0
para que esta expresión sea 0 x tiene
que ser igual a menos 4 y la otra
solución es x igual a 3 así es que este
de aquí es el caso cuando x es igual a
menos 4 y esté aquí es el caso cuando x
es igual a 3 ya casi hemos terminado nos
falta encontrar los valores de guía
correspondientes y para eso usemos la
ecuación más simple que es igual a x1
así es que cuando x es igual a menos 4 y
es igual a menos cuatro más uno menos
tres y es igual a menos tres es este
punto de aquí este es el punto menos
cuatro coma menos tres y de manera
análoga cuando x es igual a tres que es
igual a 4 este es el punto 3,4
y ahora si estas dos son las soluciones
de este sistema de ecuaciones no
lineales